President Trump says plans are well
underway for a meeting with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un but he also says if
the talks are not quote fruitful you may
walk out or cancel the meeting entirely
the president spoke in depth about North
Korea after a two-day summit with
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
major Garrett is traveling with the
president he's in West Palm Beach
major good morning good morning
president Trump and prime minister Ave
according to two senior officials had
very tough knocked-down talks over trade
so in public they can find most of their
remarks to a topic whether it's more
agreement North Korea the president
introduced cautionary words about that
much-anticipated summit while the Prime
Minister praised what he called the
president's quote remarkable and
decisive leadership I will be meeting
with Kim jong-un in the coming weeks to
discuss the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula appearing with Japanese
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a president
Trump said the anticipated summit with
North Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon
might not happen or resolve differences
if I think that it's a meeting that is
not going to be fruitful we're not going
to go if the meeting when I'm there is
not fruitful I will respectfully leave
the meeting summit planning continues
and possible locations include the peace
village inside the Korean Demilitarized
Zone a u.s. naval ship off the Korean
coast or neutral locations ranging from
Mongolia to Sweden there's a good chance
of doing it we're having very good
dialogue the president said negotiations
also include seeking the release of an
American businessman and two teachers
imprisoned in North Korea I'm working
hard to get to every senator that vote
that camp
CIA director Mike Pompeo s nomination
for Secretary of State is facing an
uncertain future he just left
North Korea
with kim jeongmin the white house is
using Pompey's clandestine North Korea
trip meant to lay groundwork for a
summit to underscore the need for Senate
confirmation it's better to be talking
Senator Bill Nelson a Democrat who
opposed Pompey's nomination for CIA
director said the North Korean gambit
could change his mind
that puts him in a better light in my
mind yes the president also said
Kentucky Republican Senator Rand Paul
currently and no on pompeius
confirmation vote will come around
saying quote he'll never let me down
after the president called Paul
yesterday the senator agreed to meet
with Pompeo John major one other piece
of business do we expect the White House
to announce new sanctions on Russia for
its alleged involvement in that chemical
attack in Syria well the president was
walking away from the podium yesterday
when many of us myself included asked
him why he had personally delayed those
sanctions the president said those
sanctions will come when Russia very
much deserves it
a phrase clearly opened for
interpretation
president also said no one has been
tougher than him on Russia and chastised
the media for not giving him credit on
that in the end John it was the
president's intervention that stopped
those sanctions now they're gonna have
to come and when they do the president
likely will be the one to announce it
all right major things still trying to
sort out that two-step with the UN
Ambassador saying these sanctions are
coming and the president saying nope
yeah her line with all due respect I
don't get confused I guess that's one of
the responses on time